[Music] I
just carry dumbbells when I move, and this is
really, really bad value for money. It's hard, so
I
bring it with me. All hotels have gyms anyway, so who's the strongest?  Come on, is there anyone who
draws inspiration from you in terms of style now? It’s
not that person.
Rather than a specific person,
I see
it a lot on Instagram.  This is
omega 3. Please
tell me the effect of this. Look for it.
This is magnesium, so it has vitamin b.  It was
so hard to find, so I
started using this mainstream version from then on, but it has
sensibility,
good sound quality, and
less things to lose.
There are a few of them, but if you
combine them with the Nintendo DS, it's still about enough. The picture
quality is better.
Music]
Actually, I started with an English note, but
this morning I put n Japanese on it for the direct meeting.
[Music]
Normally, my hair is a bit
longer now, so I think I'm trying to cover it up with a beanie. Even
when I practice,
because of my long hair  Now that I cover my front,
I think I use my hair
separately. I always carry [Music] perfume. I
like something sweet,
but there
are so many types of sweet
things.  See,
really
[Music]
[Music] You
have to do this in between. Anyway,
all exercises
are done with your hands. That's why it's important. You
have to have grip strength. You can do everything.  You have to
listen to the songs
acdc jaker
candles
so you can lift more weight.  I
need to chew it when it's full.
There will be about 10 tubes like this in my bag. This is my
lotion. This is my
lotion.  It's
tickling. Everyone here,
everyone, like this
[Music]